you're a guy who makes people laugh
profession what makes you laugh the
hardest Oh what I want to know that you
know what and I thought of you know
actually makes me laugh is that is the
Cinemax softcore stuff like when they're
the sexy no I don't like the sex scenes
I want DVDs of all of those movies
without the sex scenes so I can just see
the people reacting yes the acting is
actually kind of towards the guy that's
like hey what are you guys doing here
you know I mean like that I want I want
to be best friends with that guy I want
to be in one of those I brought a clip
actually you brought up a brush tip of
one of my favorite ones so this isn't a
clip of any of your work no I do that of
some of a porn movie non sex scene porn
movie yeah that you want to just show us
all it's called what's it called The
Devil's honey I'm Jeff devil's something
that's really all you need to know is it
sinfully delightful do you know what I
mean
let's take a look everything I love is
in you I need you I need all of you know
because you don't want me you want a
piece of me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you understand how good that acting
is for wait a minute but what do you
understand what happened zipped up his
pants yes and they've got real curious
she got curious this is why that's the
best act together because I love the
movie Mulholland Drive I have no idea
what it's about
also that movie to both David Lynch film
that's a good choice wasn't that a great
clip subscribe to my youtube channel for
an endless supply of me
[Laughter]